how is the screenwriting masters program
transformed your screenwriting process
what do you do differently now well I I
think a lot more about the structure
from the very beginning then the way
that I used to do it previously I would
start just by sort of I had an idea for
a movie I would just start writing and
just sort of see where it went and
sometimes good things would come from
that there definitely is a benefit to
sort of free writing and just you know
kind of seeing what comes from it but my
experience has taught me that spending
time to outline an idea before actually
writing it makes the writing much more
efficient I I've saved multiple drafts
of screenplays because I've gone and
I've outlined ahead of time and I
figured out the the major you know
turning points of the film and that sort
of thing that's something I really
didn't do beforehand because I sort of
rebelled against it I thought that you
know structure is the enemy and the
thing that I've learned is structure is
your friend
it helps point out errors before you get
to them and it helps you helps you stay
on track if you know what the next thing
is that you're writing towards it's a
lot better if it's five pages away then
if it's fifty pages away so you know
that you have a specific thing to write
to your scenes have more urgency your
scenes your scenes have more conflict as
a result of that so that's I think
that's the biggest thing that I've
learned and the other thing that I sort
of picked up along the way is the more
personal that you can make your stories
and the more raw you can make them I
think the more effective they are for
the reader the story that I wrote about
my dad there were some really dark
things that were in there and it's not a
dark film per se it is a drama but
really laying there some emotional
things that that I had dealt with you
know a long time ago it really helps
with the you know it helps with the
writing it makes it more it makes it
more engaging it makes it
or interesting for the reader you know
the more you try to cover up sort of the
the raw things that your characters are
dealing with the less interesting it
becomes so I think I think it's good to
kind of lay it all out there it's kind
of a form of free therapy I know you'd
said another class from another
professor that they talked about
deciding what type of protagonist you
really want to focus on did you did you
start to see parallels and who you
wanted to write about and you know it's
funny I I have and and I see it now in
the film that I'm that I'm making now
that it really is even though the
characters in this film that we're
making now have nothing to do with me
and my time in my life because they're
all in their 20s their struggles are
exactly what I'm dealing with now it's
it really is interesting how
subliminally you sort of inform your
work with the stuff that you're dealing
with in your life and you know the
issues that you really care about in the
end that you struggle with it's it's
really an interesting thing I thought I
was trying to get away from that but you
really can't
it really was there so you see that a
lot of the movies that you've been drawn
toward have a similar protagonists I
think so yeah you know people that are
trying to do good but that have come
from really hardscrabble really
struggling circumstances you know either
emotionally or socioeconomically those
are the kinds of characters that I
really I really gravitate to you know
one of my favorite films ever was a
phone called short-term 12 that was brie
Larson's first real leading role before
she got into a room at one of the Oscar
and that film is about a woman who it
works at a home for troubled teens and
she herself was a troubled teen when she
was growing up so she sort of enmeshed
in that world and she's struggling to
get out of it you know but it's hard
because you know you're surrounded by
all this trauma you know that I'd that
really resonated with me
because it's sometimes it's hard to
break out of that kind of life when you
grow up
in it and eventually you know her
character does she does move on in a way
so it's that that was a film I really
loved so those kinds of characters you
know that are really struggling with
moving on from a world that they know
even though it's negative that kind of
story really connects
you